why do you think I'm so happy
every day I believe I are you a happy
guy yes I'm an extremely happy guy do
you work hard to be happy is it
something you constantly work at no no
no I don't or I do constantly let's talk
it through my natural reaction to you is
no I don't know what part of me let's
talk about let's break it down because I
think you'll find this interesting my my
mom lost her mom at five my dad lost his
dad at 15 I can tell you the majority of
my childhood I thought about my parents
dying it was a constant flow so I
constantly worked in my head as a 7 9 11
13y old child hey I woke up hey this
another day that they're here this is
good this is a good day so I naturally
say to you no I don't have to work at it
because now I'm at a 48y Old State and I
forget and I'm trying to tap in harder
to like talk this through with you
mentally I always am talking to myself
about perspective class half full yes I
think about things I'll tell this is
like real life to me I know it's a
little weird or not talked about as much
but I'll sit here I'll do this podcast
this so lovely what we're doing now I'm
enjoying this and I'll then like
literally take the feelings I have right
now which is a lot of joy and energy and
like as we transition and walk out and
talk with team photos talk a little bit
talk about this startup like as we do
that a part of my brain will be like hey
this will really happen hey G do you
know since you've been here with them
like a lot of people passed away in a
bad car accident wow yeah how I told you
it's a little weird so much half full
anymore just dumped out that water no
it's actually I would almost call it
extreme gratitude
it's this constant flow in my head of
like just deep gratitude and it's a
constant conversation and so it's funny
I acted very fast and say to you no but
boy I'm not sure how many people on
earth walk around and are constantly
talking themselves about perspective and
keeping simple and like just be
grateful for what's going and yes this
is challenging this is hard in personal
life this is hard at work but like
as long as these 17 10 nine people that
are closest to me are healthy then like
today's a great day and that
helps me a lot so so maybe I am working
at it so and it's a constant there's
nobody that's just happy happiness
doesn't happen contentment doesn't
happen relationships don't just happen
that for sure it's a it's a it's because
the first one's one-on-one basketball
it's you with you right you start
bringing another variable in that's a
whole another
world
he